SPEAKER 1: You
became a developer
because you love games.
You always wanted to take
them beyond what we know,
to create truly innovative
and interesting experiences.
You had an idea which
you had the courage
to turn into reality.
You learned skills
you didn't have.
You constantly learn
and adapt and make
decisions every single day.
You think you're
prepared, then you
realize there's always
something new to learn.
It's risky and scary and at
the same time, exhilarating--
the freedom to create,
the collaboration
with other like-minded
people, the sleepless nights,
the coffees, the looks from
your family and friends,
the leaps of faith, the
pride in what you do.
There are ups-- your first
drawing, the first time
you make something
move using code,
the moment you get
it out to the world,
the reaction of the first
person who tries it out.
That's what it's all about.
There are many downs.
You mess up on the way,
but you don't give up.
When you fail, you learn.
You continue with passion,
creativity, pushing yourself
forward, and the next day comes.